so here's the next story that we're
going to get into trump tweets video of
chinese professor claiming that beijing
can swing u.s policy
because it has people at the top of
america's core inner circle of power
in clip that has been deleted from
social media in china not only
does this guy d dongsheng say that they
have uh
they have old friends he calls it in
high positions
he says that joe biden's son became rich
with all this international financing
stuff and
who do you think helped him do it
essentially it's saying
the bidens are compromised but he
doesn't need to say it because tony
babilinski
already said it yeah that joe biden is
compromised by china
and now we have a guy in china they're
all laughing as he says he did it
this is this is the consequence now of
losing this election
yeah no i i'm i'm really not happy about
that
you know and i think but so listen
listen
what do you do what do you do uh you you
try and beat him or
i mean or well and one of the things
i've been talking about has been let's
get a special counsel going
right like this is what the democrats
did let's have a special counsel for
bain and
biden and china and if they if they end
the election
and the election yeah let's have a
second like we should have three right
there's durham already
but let's have a new one for the china
barisma stuff
and let's have one for the election
irregularities and let's make the
democrats adhere
you know if the democrats want like
obviously a democrat attorney general
can
figure out a way to fire these people
there are ways yeah but if they want to
set that precedent fine we're never
going to have to deal with another
bs investigation from the civil service
again right and so i mean i think they
probably will end up doing that if we
took the you know if barr pulled the
trigger was it was it look was it lebron
james
who came out all pro china was yeah
lebron's right yeah
we've been seeing more and more u.s
companies capitulate to china
authoritarian despots communists who
harvest organs from religious minorities
and they're bragging now that they've
essentially got
the incoming president in their back
pocket yeah it's kind of funny how like
the communist government of china ended
up proving every critique of capitalism
true
uh right like yeah you you end up with
i mean all the worse sort of
rapaciousness and corruption
they were able to go to these these
harvard professors these what
what what are the universities where
they arrested all these guys oh yeah i
mean it was harvard berkeley i think had
one
they go to professor and say hey we'll
give you fifty thousand dollars a month
give us your secrets
recruit for us and they say you bet oh
man not only to them but to u.s soldiers
to military personnel with top secret
clearances just like that nypd officer
that was taken in
and also other governments like israel
that have sold u.s technology
to china so this is a major issue that's
going to have major implications i want
to know
who is this top american core the inner
circle of power
influence who are these people i want i
want to know there deserves to be an
investigation
deep state well there you go top level
let's call the old friends i'm going to
call him the old friends from now on he
did extensively talk about
wall street and how wall street was able
to contain someone like obama that was
very easy to manipulate and then he said
when trump came in
the story wasn't uh so true and then he
thinks that when binding comes in things
are going to go back to normal what's
normal what is this normal according to
beijing and the chinese
government the pinky ring of the chinese
communist party yeah trump wouldn't do
it
this guy was like how do we fix the
trump administration we couldn't do it
well then biden won and everyone laughs
everyone laughs
so look uh sam harris tweeted the other
day the story from the new york times
why do so many people think the election
was rigged
and jeffrey miller so now these another
professor responded that when when
there's so much anti-conservative bias
in academia and institutions in the
media
people just don't trust the elections
right but it's crazy to me that
we have joe biden the single greatest
president in american history
um based on his ability i mean you have
to imagine um
the amount of votes he got 80 million
and and the amount of campaigning he did
basically none he must have been the
most
powerfully charismatic individual i can
only imagine when he when he
got up on tv and he said come on man
every single you know one of these
voters just like
was blasted back by the pure awe of joe
biden's characters
i don't know i mean he you know hillary
was a really bad candidate in a lot of
ways people really didn't like hillary
clinton and they had really good reason
not to like her
you know the thing about biden he's a
goofball
he's in cognitive decline but nobody
hated him right
right he's not as trump trump wasn't a
threat he it's like dude
who loathes joe biden there might be a
few people
like and maybe he's done some really low
some things like with china scott but
like
tara reid yeah tara reid i mean yeah you
know there there are there are certainly
scandals that are loathsome
but personality wise he he's not like
hillary and he's not like a lot of
democrats who are just
you know well so so let me ask you this
let me let me uh load the the question
up a little bit
joe biden beat every non-polling
bellwether metric
such as voter enthusiasm party
registration numbers
uh uh google searches which is a new one
there's uh primary vote count and and
support
he also won the other silly ones like
cookie sales and mass
i'm sorry he lost are you talking about
you know trump won all these inviting
beat them he so basically all of these
things were against him
so whoever gets the heist enthusiasm
tends to win whoever gets the
best primary turnout tends to win
whoever gets the most uh um
new registration tends to win whoever
sells the most halloween masks and most
cookies those are the silly ones i bring
them up on purpose
joe biden lost all of those things and
still won he lost the three bellwether
states and 18 of 19 below the townships
so when you say all that a lot of people
say
look if you came up to me and said he
beat a few of these things i'd be like
wow
you come on you tell me that he beat
every single one of them
at once and that's the weird i mean it's
it's weird and i think
i think certainly there is not
impossible but it's it's just not
impossible and in 2020 was a different
election
it's true it's true what i always often
say people got to realize too is that
kovid moved everybody around
that people were moving and the riots
moved everybody around so that could
explain the states and
the townships i suppose but we also have
to understand that who was in biden's
corner
china was in his corner the big tech
monopolies were in this corner
hollywood was in his corner the
mainstream media was in this
the establishment was in his you know
corner and they all are working together
helping each other out so it makes you
really wonder what really happened here
especially with the latest revelations
from this professor from beijing i mean
this is mind-blowing stuff
did you i mean what he said about hunter
and how the hunter story was
treated in the united states it was
essentially stuffed out
the american public were denied the
truth about the hunter biden emails
because of the mainstream media and big
tech social monopolies collusion
destroying it this is what the professor
said trump has been saying that biden's
son has some sort of global foundation
have you noticed that who helped hunter
build
the foundation got it there are a lot of
these
deals inside you know you need to
understand the way he said it
yes the laughing and smiling he didn't
just say and who helped him build it got
it he went
and who helped him built it yeah and
everyone laughs got it
right our old friends the political
establishment the elites the old guard
the people who are in government who are
helping us out
he says i talked to our friends they
said they were trying to help but they
couldn't stop trump
well then biden gets biden wins he
smiles and everyone laughs
so look man i'm uh i'm not uh
i i think i think dark times are coming
dark winter is
is is putting it lightly i mean i i hope
that we win the georgia senate races
really really badly i think i don't
think so well a lot of republicans are
disenfranchised
because you know trump's being kind of
quiet he's not really being bombastic
he's not really
fighting and then everything just looks
like it's not going his way so
but trump's not on the ticket yet people
don't like the republicans
i mean in georgia right like you know
the the senate candidates outperform
trump
right but like loveller was appointed
yeah i mean they're not there's not
huge enthusiasm behind them but right
you know this sort of she
she didn't win a popularity contest
right yeah i mean there's a vacancy
outright there are overall more
republican votes in both the senate
seats i think it's still pretty viable
for us to win those senate seats
i i i agree i'm just leaning towards and
maybe i'll be wrong again because i you
know i'm not good at predicting how
people vote i suppose
uh or i am and i'm not good at
predicting how fraud plays out
um but that's the case that democrats
win i don't know i mean like
like basically i i speak to some
personal experience like my parents are
classic suburban republicans
right and they uh my mom couldn't stand
trump she just couldn't
right you know and voted for hillary and
voted for biden um
but even she called me the other day and
said i'm like i'm i really you know i'm
really still glad trump went to georgia
to get those republican senate
candidates elected like there
there really are there really is that
constituency of people
um in in certain places like georgia
that
just couldn't couldn't stomach trump but
would generally want republicans in
power
well let's let's let's talk about the
more severe reality of what comes next
this is from uh we got yahoo news fbi
warns state
local police about china targeting
people on u.s soil
they say the fbi is warning local law
enforcement agencies to be aware of
cooperating with a chinese government
campaign
to coerce u.s residents to return to
china
to face criminal charges according to a
counterintelligence bulletin obtained by
yahoo news
the bulletin comes shortly after eight
people including a former new york
police department officer were indicted
on charges of acting as a legal agents
for beijing
eight people including a new nypd
officer were i mean how is this not
treason well he wasn't just an nypd
officer it's he also
held a very important security clearance
because he was in the military as well
in the us military in the u.s military
as well and he was spying on the tibetan
community
which was a protest community that he
was going back all the way to china
giving out key information who was a
part of organizing against the chinese
government
do you see what mike pompeo said earlier
this year i'm not i mean
he said a lot of things he said china's
infiltrated every level of government
from the state city that's very true
so i i feel like this guy getting up on
stage
in china and gloating that the bidens
are basically
in the pockets of the old friends and
seeing the story about hunter biden let
me just make something really really
clear
joe biden took hunter bite on an air
force 2 to china for a private equity
deal
why did joe biden use u.s government
resources
to help his son get a five million
dollar forgivable
interest-free loan from china and launch
a you know billion dollar
billion dollar equity firm they're
they're they're in the pocket it's
beijing
bob yalinski who worked with the family
gave an interview saying they're
compromised
and that's it we just roll over and say
we we're all chinese subjects now
second-class citizen unless we can't
even go to china i mean
china poses such a difficult problem
like i i often people think like it was
just obvious that
you know we were gonna win the cold war
i mean we had a massive espionage
disadvantage of the soviet union
yeah um but ultimately the soviet union
was you know fighting us but they had
a completely dysfunctional economic
system they couldn't put enough toilet
paper on the shelves
you know they didn't put enough toilet
paper on the shelves now yeah i mean
right um but like it took 50 years to
beat that gu that
economy and that economy was completely
dysfunctional china's economy is not
dysfunctional no
um it's manipulative it's manipulative
and they're down
and they're also have the same sort of
like espionage superiority of us that
the soviets had overraised
they have four times the people four
times the people i mean in terms of
agents like we don't have any meaningful
presence there they have
i mean there's some great books on this
about what
the var variety of different operations
china's running here
trying to hack lower level defense
contractors because they can't hack
obviously this you know drd but they try
and get low-level contractors and get
plans that way
um you know basically trying to recruit
people i mean there are
i think something that somebody said to
me or i think i might have read it
there are like serious technical
computer science programs at college
park
taught by chinese professors to chinese
students in chinese
and that's weird like that's and then
those kids go back
they're they're they're they're
manipulating their uh real estate market
in china
yeah to create this this like a regular
middle-class house is like a million
dollars compared to an
american which is you know 200 to 300
000 or something like that they're
buying up large swaths of land
in countries all over the world in uh in
brazil in in africa
in uh in the us on the west on the west
coast they're buying up tons and tons of
property
they're just slowly buying their way to
take everything over
yeah it's clever it's basically they've
convinced the united states
to give up all its manufacturing in
exchange for cheap labor
these politicians we've had over the
past several decades the old friends as
as
dong chang says have uh thought to
themselves
look it's good for the american business
to have
dollar an hour chinese laborers i've got
to pay benefits to they save money and
we all get rich
and then a generation goes by decade
goes by and now we no longer make our
own medicine
we don't like you buy a musical
instrument you buy you know
computer computers cameras whatever it's
all made somewhere else we don't make it
anymore
yeah what would happen if china declared
war right now we'd be caught with our
pants down
i mean it's i mean they wouldn't i mean
there's there's still the mutual assured
destruction worries but i mean they
were beyond the point of being able to
you know really meaningfully coerce them
like that's and that's that's actually
different from like where we were as a
superpower even 20 years ago
um like and and that's sort of you know
we at human events i mean we ran an
article
like xi jinping will have his way in
hong kong and that was like two years
ago yeah we got a lot of flak from that
from people who were saying
but like we you know again a descriptive
versus a narrative argument do i want xi
jinping to have his way with hong kong
no will he yes exactly this beijing
professor confirmed everything that
we've been
hearing about fair very we were talking
about this two days ago before two years
ago
we were breaking everything down and we
got to understand we're in the trade war
we're going to going to be in a currency
war where probably
according to the cities trap might be
even in a hot war
and we have to understand china has its
hands deep
in american institutions like we can't
even imagine
when we look at politicians and
corporations they have been
enriched more than they could have even
imagined because of this
opening of china policy that has been
instituted by individuals like henry
kissinger under the nixon administration
that literally went to china with david
rockefeller and said
hey we're going to have a lot of jobs
for you we're going to bring you a lot
of factories we're going to bring you a
lot of industry
you just give us the cheap chinese slave
labor and then we're going to have a
great deal and all everything's going to
go through china and that's exactly
what's happening right now look
it's it's beyond just the schools where
they have a thousand towns project where
they've actually
got a bunch of professors taking 50k a
month or whatever recruiting more people
and selling our secrets
they're they've got hollywood bending
the knee doing movies where they remove
negative things that could offend china
the nba is praising them
and they got tick tock and mainstream
media as well mainstream news articles
refuse
many times to even criticize china or
the uyghur muslims
what i mean look at tibet as an example
a few years ago everyone was talking
about tibet and the tibetans and the
things that they're going through with
the chinese government
now no one's even talking about tibet no
one's talking about the uyghur muslims
so let's talk about
the hong kong where we're getting video
footage right now of them
sending activists and protesters to
mainland china to never be seen
again or the video footage of the uyghur
muslims yeah being loaded to trains
all that's happening and it sounds like
if
trump isn't the president in the next
four years we will just
be subjects of china i mean i don't
think we'll be subjects of china i think
that we're too late
figuratively but like it'll get to the
point where literally whatever soft
power we had i mean
like it just it will be gone right like
we'll ask someone we're we're we're a
generation or two out you know
you see what tick tock is doing people
don't realize this with without how tic
tac works
um you know what i'm gonna stop and talk
about a different social media app
okay that's similar and what they do is
and i've mentioned this before
you get in order to get a bunch of young
people using your social media app so
you can manipulate them and control what
they see and what they think
you you get some kids to use it you give
them fake followers
all of a sudden some high school kids
like i got 2 000 followers on this app
like i don't have any followers on
facebook or twitter they use the app
more they get more followers the
followers aren't real
they brag to their friends you got how
many followers do you have 50
i got 4 000 on tick tock or i should say
a different app not not tic tac no i
mean literally different yeah
uh because i don't know if tic tac did
this but i know there's another company
that
did this and it worked out very very
very very well for them
you get all these young people to use it
and eventually you've created a cultural
wave that everybody wants to be on it
because they want to get recognition
they want the followers they want the
points they want the score
then you use the algorithm to control
what they can see and what they can't
see
all of a sudden now anything negative
about china is gone everything positive
about china's coming back
donald trump is the orange man he's
awful he's evil he's bad everybody hates
him right you better go vote
then you get a big surge of young people
who go out and vote and that's
manipulated
through the technology coming from these
other countries it's fifth generational
warfare
i mean there's a reason china doesn't
let its citizens use twitter exactly but
they use it they use it on our
for us yeah like i mean there needs to
be reciprocity there nothing at all
right like and we should be i mean it's
ridiculous that it took so long or that
people were even pushing back against
the problem of chinese
and they're aggressively going after
vpns so people in china can't even
you know change their addresses to see
what people in the world are saying so
just imagine living in china where your
social credit score relies on what you
regurgitate what you read if you read
something you're not supposed to read
your social credit score goes down
and this is a society that other places
like singapore and other governments are
even
thinking about adapting themselves
because this is a great way to control
people to subjugate people and to
benefit the special interest
class which are seeing these things
they're saying wait this could be
probably good here and then we have
a biden administration where his cabinet
is being filled with individuals that
are literally arguing
we can't do anything to stifle we
shouldn't stop china because if we do
that's going to hurt the global economy
we need to let china rise
and these are key individuals that are
going to be in biden's administration
very soon just lay down and put your
hands up and expose your soft underbelly
for china that's why we they just want
to lock up the uyghur muslims we need
satellite internet
uh we need to bypass isps and get this
free software mesh network into place
we need it here because so we don't get
censored but they need it
yeah i mean free and open internet is
something critically important and when
you see china controlling it
controlling what their people can and
cannot listen to and see
this is a huge vast power that it just
started out with saying
with the government coming out saying no
we're going to tell you what you should
listen to
we know what's best for you just like
corporations are making the argument
here
we have to fight against fake news and
everything that's wrong in our society
we're going to curate everything for you
and provide it to you on a silver
platter i think we're on track to
based on everything we're seeing
happening right now when i say that
we'll be subjects of of china
i don't mean in a year i mean in 50 or
100
we will be a weak old regional power
probably fractured in many ways with a
you know disparate broken government in
some
i imagine at that point you know and
again a lot of variables from now
between the 50 or 100 years
but uh china's got the power china's
growing china is controlling
us and we're losing
i don't know i'm i'm i would say i'm
that as pessimistic as you are but i
definitely think that we're in general i
mean the democrats are
you know continuing democrat control
will lead to that sure look at look at
the past several decades of what us has
been doing sending our manufacturing
overseas
trans-pacific partnership now you know
joe biden's going to
jump in whatever pacific partnership
agreement there's going to be
and it's not just about china they're
they're
they're the biggest threat the us has
right now but it's also about the u.s
just giving up
and it's not like the collective spirit
of america has said oh i failed i'm done
it's that we've got politicians that
never cared about us
and it's partly our fault when people go
and they say i'm a vote democrat
i'm voting republican they don't know
who they're voting for they end up
voting for people who are just like
vote for me and you know i'll fight for
you i'll give you whatever you want and
then all they really wanted was the keys
to the castle
they want to get the paycheck they want
to get the pension and they want to get
their name etched in stone for history
and then they did nothing and then when
it came to passing bills they said
how much money can we we make in the
short term if we send our manufacturing
to you know to mexico to indonesia
to you know to uh vietnam or china we'll
make a ton of money in the short term
what about the long term
oh we'll lose yeah but we won't care
about that that's our kids right
politicians have sold out the next
generations and so surprised to me
you've got so many young people who are
becoming socialists
that seems to me like the downward
trajectory is
we had a period where a bunch of our
leaders were selling our manufacturing
base
for a short-term gain with a long-term
loss
and then we created this world where
these kids are like well just go to
college then right
that's the solution there's no more good
manufacturing jobs go to college
and you'll get a good paying job but
what happens when everybody has a degree
in some field or another and you're
competing with people on the same level
once again
there are still no jobs there can be a
million good computer jobs
but if you know 50 million kids are
coming out of college with computer
degrees there's still no jobs
now they're saying nothing works we need
communism but communism doesn't produce
anything it extracts things
so over a long enough period of time as
everyone keeps demanding the government
pay my bills
we need a stimulus lock everything down
have the government pay for it
the government can print money money can
facilitate trade but if there's nothing
being produced there's nothing to trade
in the long run
yeah i think that's right thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you